so once protected so because she got
married she's protected by law because
of the yes
can we be real about life
i'm just taking it i'm not disagreeing
i'm not saying it to make it clear
if we're being clear about life
like you said we have two women in
identical positions but one is married
and one is not
if you're not married and it all goes
pear-shaped you're gone you're out
there's nothing you can't go nowhere and
say well he cheated on me i should get
half sorry love you're not married
forget about it if you're married
you're entitled yeah yeah in life let's
be real you're getting half okay cool
i've been cheated on emotionally you
might be sad for a bit mm-hmm but again
as they say do you want to cry
in a bentley or in a fiat panda okay
this is a reality
you want to get cheated on and go and
stay go back home to your mom or stay in
a room with your friend
or do you want to get the house
i was talking first and men look at and
men look at ex-wives and ex-girlfriends
different okay so men look at men look
at ex-wives and ex-girlfriends different
because because one has results and they
can say oh that man chose her she was
worth being chosen where a girl that's
that's over a certain age they're like
why did nobody choose you because i know
other guys aren't stupid so why didn't
anyone choose you why aren't you so then
the two women that were both 20 years
old that got cheated on at 25 or
whatever and then one was married one
wasn't if now they're both 30 and in
that 10 years they were so heartbroken
couldn't admit date anyone else they're
now 30 with a child one was married one
wasn't you would go for the pudding
they're left over then put in left over
so no so you wouldn't go for either of
them like why are you getting divorced
for when you got married why are you
getting divorced because i've just said
nothing women didn't know you're not
listening to what i just said
situations no i said both were twenty
one was married one wasn't they both had
a child each one they both were cheated
on and then after ten five ten years or
whatever now they're ready to date again
because they couldn't date when they had
a young baby or whatever now the child
is five six seven eight years old too
young today and they're sorry that's too
young what's too young have you got a
child five years old
and you've been mad you guys are adding
extra stuff like just i'm trying to get
to your reality she's been from reality
now that the the two women that one was
20 both were 20 one was married one
wasn't whatever whatever they've now
come to 26 27 eight whatever years old
you're saying that the one that was
married that divorce she's more valuable
than the one that wasn't i'm just trying
to man yeah yeah so then you would date
the one that so you would still go for
that one with a child who was divorced
yep one yeah more like okay
and the number can we stop acting like
like men are out here cheating all the
time the majority matter
but i'm saying what i'm saying
i'm saying i'm saying i'm saying the
majority of men aren't even having sex
okay so
number one and then wait guys wait and
then wait wait and the number one reason
for divorce is financial reasons okay so
i'm just going off the conversation that
was happening before you gave a scenario
of two women one both twenty one one
divorced one did it who gave i didn't
give that to you well that was
guys but i was trying to make another
point like if the man got the most
valuable women ever because she was
young pretty whatever
why they still
leave
those women
do they do because i know quite a lot of
single mother
so they've been left alone so single for
those single mothers
being left alone being left alone the
man leave or did they choose the men the
men the men
married
i like honestly speaking like i have
very close
very close no very close relationship
also like people that i know very
closely that
like they coming from uh divorced
parents and she was the first like she
was the virgin we're talking about
he had two children and then after he
left for what for
honestly speaking so
like what we're talking about man anyway
can get even the best women ever the
most vulnerable that we're talking about
whatever in our best she can give him
her best
by and large it's not true the women are
leaving it's not men
okay
honestly i came next time i'm gonna come
with number two so probably i'm gonna
prove the stories that you have are
probably the exception the two that's
quite a lot there's quite a lot of
single patterns single mapping single
quite a lot yeah quite low it's probably
like 15
15 or more why not yeah and that's a
my new amount to the whole thing and so
what
they're saying is i see more divorced
divorced couples than marriage buyers so
in your in your circle would you say men
left more than women yeah definitely
from people that you know yeah men have
more than women yeah
yeah and the thing is that a lot of what
women don't fail to realize is
how hard it is for a man to get married
in the first place but not take that
lightly
men don't take it lightly and i don't
think they realize the importance that
every man decides to put a ring on your
finger
he can have 15 women out there he
decided to put a ring on your finger
that means something because marriage
does not come easy to men if a man
decides that's who i'm going to marry
that puts you up there wherever you
think whether he's got 15 women or not
but that person because they're married
men are men are risking losing
everything like men men are risky
men no men are risking ruin their
ruining their entire life if they marry
you because they're because you can
leave take half their [ __ ] and take the
kids with you and then they have to pay
you to take their kids yeah because they
don't even mind probably about their
children
is that is that what you think of men
some of them yes
because if you want to build a real
relationship you
gonna
very
you're gonna look for someone that
actually can deal with everything and
when i'm saying everything i don't mean
cheating because loyalty is actually on
the basement of every relationship so if
you want you know men have lost their
entire life savings trying to get
custody of their kids from mother's day
i know because like me personally
i know about i had two brothers and
they've been they coming from uh first
my my dad first married so i know quite
well so i'm talking about something that
actually be involved during my life so i
know what i'm talking about
but i'm saying that's that's such a high
risk for a guy
so if a guy's putting a rail willing to
put a ring on your finger that means
something like you just took actually
the right uh example because like
my dad had two children from a woman who
was the virgin we're talking about see
she was 18 years old when she met my dad
and they had two two children
and the marriage and up all right and my
dad actually fight to you know see the
children all right
so
you see even though she was the
most like i mean obviously considering
your standard so your standard guys
she was a very valuable girl but anyway
the marriage end up and who win i will
say no one definitely my brothers they
suffered quite a lot
but
she didn't win because she had the ring
because after my dad married another my
mother yeah and then then she kept the
actually
actually yeah that's that's horrible
yeah this this is horrible win so she
won because she had the ring who won in
this story
did she win it just means she won more
than the girl who never got the ring it
doesn't mean she won in life the one who
wins is the one now
the one who wins is the one who gets
married and stays married that's who
wins no i i think she had a very very
sad life
because
you know when you get that angry